let's say that inflation isn't 5.1 or
5.4 wherever it comes in on a monthly
basis now and we all agree it's
something that is higher but there's
disagreement on how much higher is it 6
or is it 14 what happens to all the
people who are using cpi as the
benchmark do they just succumb to the
inflation over time and continue to lose
money until they wake up or something
else i think a lot of people have a
hybrid situation like um
for example um let's say i run a real
estate trust or i run a real estate
company and i have a hundred million
dollars
a year worth of rental income
it's capped at cpi does the leases are
assigned 10 years 20 years 30 years
duration five years duration and then
you've got all the trade relationships
like i can't go to i can't go to the
people that rent my
building and tell them that the
inflation rate's 14
right i mean would you pay a 14 increase
in your rent here no no no so there's a
certain inertia in parts of the economy
where they're going to
move up at cpi or they're going to be
flat or maybe they can do double cpi but
at the same time maybe you're the person
running that real estate company you're
thinking well i'm going to take my cash
flows and i'm going to invest them in
would you invest them in a stock that
you thought would go up at cpi or would
you invest them in the s p index if you
thought you would get cpi not really
yeah so what you have is you have people
that are sweeping their cash flows from
an operating business
that's low growth and they're putting in
the s p index if you know they're
looking for the growth to come from the
investors okay the s p is up 34
how many companies in the world
generated 34
more cash flow or raised their prices by
34
or grew their revenues 34 in the last 12
months
not many right 98
99
they're in a they're in a
a fiat operating system where
they're going to raise their prices or
generate cash flows at a rate slower
than
the rate of monetary inflation
but those same people will turn around
and they'll buy bitcoin
or they'll buy property or that you may
buy property that you is going up faster
right
there's not a single commercial rent
there's not a single commercial lease i
think in the world where they raised the
price of the rent 27 percent in the last
12 months right
at least
i can't imagine if you had a lease no
one's got it capped at the case-shiller
index
so on one hand residential property or
other types of property could actually
be accreting at a much higher rate while
your rents don't accrete at a higher
rate so
you're taking duration risk
so i
i guess the more important point is
there's a lot of capital when we think
about capital structure
like 500 trillion dollars
to 900 trillion dollars of capital
floating around there it's locked up in
structures
some of it is in currencies and and it
can move rapidly some of it is invested
in companies that can't
right move rapidly some of it is tied up
in in uh equity some of it is tied up in
in debt some of it's tied up in a trust
i have a trust my trust gave 10 million
dollars to a financial
advisor or or to a company whose
strategy is investing in uh mid-duration
corporate debt and every year i review
their performance versus their index and
over the course of a decade i might
start to
shift small amounts out
but i think that the capital is
structured in such a way there's enough
inertia in the system it could take
30 years
yeah for that for the capital to get
reallocated remember like you we're
we're waging a war on the 60 40
portfolio
right
how long will it take before people
allocate that as 65 35 or 70 30 right it
takes a long time there are people still
invested in gold you and i joke about
that
gold's been failing for 12 years or
something like that right gold's the
same price as it was when bitcoin was
invented and yet
an aggressive move would be a macro
investor allocating from 50
gold to 45
gold and 5 bitcoin and that's a bit
that's a year's work